Alex, you said that you will postpone buying a car because of the oil price hike, right?
Well, I heard in the news that after a recent conference in Bali,...
...a strategy to tackle global warming was drawn up.
But this strategy called "The Road Map" does not specify any clear emissions goal,...
...nor suggest which country should make emissions cuts...
...or how deep these cuts should be.
Rather, it just sets the framework for negotiations for a long - term agreement on emissions cuts.
But well, after reading this article,...
...I thought it was brave of you that you gave up getting a car,...
...so now, you won't emit greenhouse gas, which includes carbon dioxide.
That's one significant thing that we as citizens can do to reduce the level of carbon dioxide.
It wasn't like I did that on purpose.
But after all, I think it was a small action I could take to fight against global warming.
I did also hear news about the Bali Road Map,...
...and I was actually surprised to hear that developing countries such as China...
...or other Asian countries should limit their emissions too.
If you consider their economic development,...
...the rule is not fair for them to cut back on emissions of greenhouse gases.
Oh well, do you think the time will come when we have to purchase "clean air", like we do now with water?